python is a highle interpreted
interactive and object-oriented
scripting language python is designed to
be highly readable it uses English
keywords frequently whereas other
languages use punctuation and it has
fewer syntactic constructions than other
languages python is a widely used
programming language in web development
game development data analytics and
machine learning this video on top 10
python projects will help you learn
about some standard and exciting
projects you can create using python you
will understand making games scrapping
data from the web and building machine
learning models to solve business
problems on that note if you're looking
to become an AI expert and gain handsome
salary packages then have a look at wide
range of AI and machine learning courses
by simply learn in collaboration with
the top universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat gbt explainable AI
machine learning algorithm supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there's much more
on the list with handson experience in
tools like chat GPT d python open CV
tensorflow you will catch the eye of top
recruiters so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll now any year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses so check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details the first project we
have in our list is a sentiment and Anis
project with python sentiment analysis
is the most trending python project idea
worked upon in various Fields it uses
natural language processing text
analysis and Biometrics to
systematically identify extract and
study effective States and personal
information we use this technique in
various Fields such as e-commerce and
review poll systems libraries used to
create this project includes nltk the
python nltk module aims at providing a
complete solution to a natural language
processing problem anal helps with
everything from splitting sentences from
paragraphs splitting up words
recognizing the part of speech of those
words highlighting the principal
subjects and then allowing the machine
to understand what the text is all about
secet Lear is a machine learning library
that features various classifications
regression and clustering algorithms
including support Vector machine random
Forest gradient boosting K means and DB
scan the second project we have on our
list is customer segmentation customer
segmentation refers to the process of
dividing customers into groups based on
common characteristics or features so
companies can tend to each group
effectively and appropriately libraries
used to create this project includes
numpy numpy is a python library that
adds supports for large
multi-dimensional arrays and matrices
along with a massive collection of high
level mathematical functions to operate
on these arrays pandas pandas is a
python library for data manipulation and
Analysis it offers data structures and
operation ation for manipulating
numerical tables and time series s learn
s learn is a machine learning library
that features various classifications
regression and clustering algorithms
including spvm random forest and many it
is also designed to interoperate with
python libraries like numpy and pandas
Matt plot lib mat plot Li is a python
Library used for plotting charts and
graphs from the derived data the third
project we have in our list is an object
detection system object detection is a
computer Vision method and a popular
python project idea that allows us to
identify and locate objects in an image
or in a video we can use this technique
for various tasks to count items in a
scene and determine and track their
precise locations while accurately
labeling libraries used for this project
includes tensorflow tensorflow is a
popular python Library used for deep
learning it can be used across various
tasks but is mostly focused on training
and inference of deep learning and
neural networks opy open source computer
vision library is an open- Source python
Library used for machine learning and
computer vision it provides a common
infrastructure for computer vision
applications and speeds of machine
perception in commercial products caras
caras is an open source library that
provides a python interface for
artificial neural networks K used to
support multiple machine learning and
deep learning libraries but since
version 2.4 it acts as an interface only
for the tensor flow Library the next
project we have in our list is a Twitter
bot a Twitter bot can control and manage
a Twitter account via the Twitter API
the bot can autonomously perform all
kinds of tasks such as tweeting
retweeting linking following unfollowing
among others libraries used to create
this project includes twe twe is a
python library for accessing Twitter API
this Library enables python to
communicate with the Twitter platform
and use its API t t is the most commonly
used method for developing a graphical
user interface it is a standard inter
face to the TK GUI toolkit shipped with
python Tina is the fastest and easiest
way to create GUI applications number
five on our list is a web crawler a web
crawler often short turn to crawler is
an internet B that systematically browse
the worldwide web mostly for web
indexing web search engine and some
other websites use web crawling or
similar methods to update their web
content or indexes of other sites web
content webcrawlers copy Pages for
processing by a search engine which
indexes the downloaded pages so that
users can search more efficiently
libraries used to create this project
includes Scrappy Scrappy is a web cing
python framework it can also be used to
extract data using apis or a general
purpose web craw beautiful soup
beautiful soup is a python package for
passing HTML and XML documents it
creates a pass tree for passed pages
that can extract data from HTML which is
useful for web scripting moving on to
number six we have a currency converter
the currency converter is another python
project that involves developing a
simple software or an application that
converts one currency into another to
check its corresponding value libraries
used to create this project includes
requests the request module allows you
to send HTTP request using python the
HTTP request returns a response object
with all the response data including
content encoding status Etc Forex Forex
is a free foreign exchange rate and
currency conversion python Library it
provides several features like a list of
all currency rates Bitcoin price for all
currencies converting the amount to
Bitcoins Etc Tina tinter is the most
commonly used method for developing a
graphical user interface moving on to
number seven we have a calculator app
the calculator is a very important tool
in our daily routines if you are eager
to delve into Python Programming
creating a calculator is a
straightforward yet valuable project in
this tutorial we'll guide you through
you can create this project using tinter
with simple and comp comprehensible
steps libraries used to create this
project includes math python has a
built-in module that you can use for
mathematical tasks the math module has a
set of methods and constants tinter
tinter is the most commonly used method
for developing a graphical user
interface moving on to number eight we
have a dice rolling simulator crafting
modest project such as a text based user
interface dice rolling application is a
great way to enhance your Python
Programming pros this endeavor will
teach you the ropes of collecting and
verifying user input incorporating code
from modules and packages composing
functions leveraging for loops and
conditionals and presenting output in an
organized manner through strings and the
print function libraries used to create
this project includes random random is a
built-in module used for generating and
working with random values random
provides various methods that can be
used for creating and manipulating
random variables tinter tin is the most
commonly used method for developing a
graphical user interface a standard
interface to the TK GUI toolkit shipped
with python moving on to number nine we
have rock paper scissors embarking on
game programming is a fantastic Avenue
for mastering programming skills it
involves utilizing various tools found
in real world scenarios and the added
perk is that you get to assess your
outcomes by playing the game an
excellent starting point for your python
game programming Expedition is the
classic game of rock paper scissors
library is used random random is a
built-in python module used for
generating and working with random
values it provides various methods that
can be used for creating and
manipulating random variables Tina Tina
is the most commonly used method for
developing a GUI py game py game is a
crossplatform set of python modules
designed for coding games it provides
computer graphics and sound libraries
that are intended to be used with python
moving on to the last project for this
video we have a TI Tac to game Tic Tac 2
is another classic and the last python
project we will discuss in this video we
can implement it using mathematics iCal
functions provided by python it is a
wonderful project for grasping the
fundamentals of python library is used
random random is a built-in python
module used for generating and working
with random values numpy numpy is a
python library that adds support for
large multi-dimensional arrays and
matrices along with a massive collection
of high level mathematical functions to
operate on these arrays and last pame
pame is a crossplatform set of python
modules designed for coding games it
provides computer graphics and S
libraries that are intended to be used
with python and with that we have come
to the end of this video on top 10
python projects for
2024 if you feel that we have missed out
on something that we were supposed to
discuss in this video then please feel
free to drop them down in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will answer them for you thank you and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working profession professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success
click the link in the description to
know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here